so here is a closer look at the states
that have not yet
been called the latest figures show
joe biden with 264 electoral votes
president trump has 214.
let's go through the states now we'll
start in arizona votes there are still
being counted but
the associated press which is our main
source of election data has called that
state for joe biden
other major news outlets have not called
it yet
11 electoral college votes are up for
grabs in that state
joe biden currently has a slim lead in
nevada
the state carries six votes that he
needs to win there but
this is also the state with the largest
number of
uncounted votes now if we go to the east
coast of the u.s in georgia
16 electoral votes are on the table
there
trump has a lead but that lead has
narrowed and the trump campaign has
filed a lawsuit
alleging that ineligible late absentee
ballots
may have been added to the count
pennsylvania that's the big battleground
state it's the biggest prize still up
for grabs with 20 electoral votes
donald trump currently holds a narrow
lead but the remaining mail-in ballots
are expected
to favor the democrats
so with votes still being counted donald
trump's path to victory
it has definitely narrowed states in red
or blue have been called by
the associated press for trump or biden
states in lighter blue or pink
are leaning towards biden or trump
respectively
all right let's get an update from
washington now with my colleague
sumiso muskanda she is following the
vote counting force good evening to you
sumi so let's go through these states um
starting with
nevada we could we understand
there could be an overall result there
maybe
tomorrow evening what's the situation
what are you hearing
brent what we're hearing is that nevada
is very close right now and and it could
really be a decisive factor in this
election there are
six electoral college votes up for grabs
in the state which
uh could be really important as i said
indecisive here
now a county election official has been
speaking to the media
and he said that they will update
results tomorrow there
early afternoon there was some
disappointment brent because some people
had hoped that
we might find out more definitive
results from nevada today but the reason
for that is they're processing lots of
mail-in ballots and to add to that you
can actually or the state of nevada can
actually receive these ballots all the
way until next week and legally
according to state rules they would have
to be counted as well
it could be a very small number of
ballots we're talking about it might not
be decisive but still so much is
hanging in the balance now aztec stands
right now joe biden's lead is
at around 11 000 votes and election
officials in the state say that
um all of those ballots that were cast
in person on election day they've been
tallied so what we're waiting for is
those
mail and ballots and they have been
leaning as we heard in the report
to the democrats so joe biden's team is
very hopeful that nevada
could go their way but it's too soon to
say brent and if we go now
from the west to the east coast down
south the state of georgia the
margin of victory is going to be razor
thin
there we understand how surprising is
this
it's really surprising brent i mean you
know the last time georgia voted for a
democrat was for bill clinton in 1992
that's a long time ago
this is a republican stronghold and has
been so for many years and
right now president trump is ahead by
just around 14
000 votes but that margin has been
shrinking you know there are less than
60 000 votes left to count there and a
good number of those
are coming from fulton county where
atlanta is located
heavily favored for the democrats you
know atlanta really brent is an example
of what's been driving change in
georgia um you have these big urban
areas with the surrounding suburbs that
are home to
growing immigrant populations young
latinos people have been moving in from
other states perhaps up north and that's
been turning
patches of of georgia's map blue in a
state that was otherwise you know
a sea of red and now it is a
battleground state
and at least this year it is and that's
a new political reality for both parties
yeah and of course you know people in
the u.s and around the world still
wondering when will we have a final
result that still remains up in the air
tonight
sumi sumiskanda in washington sumi as
always thank you
well states have until december 8th to
deliver their results which is supposed
to guarantee that all votes are counted
that day is called safe harbor day
because any state result delivered
after that can be challenged now the
last time this happened
was 20 years ago in an election that was
ultimately decided
by the u.s supreme court all right for
more now we want to bring in
mary ziegler she's a professor of law at
florida state
university professor ziegler it's good
to see you again we meet on
yeah on terms that we didn't expect just
a couple of weeks ago we've got the u s
president now
threatening a number of legal challenges
if the vote does not go
his way does he have a legal basis to
stand
on when he's making these these claims
no i mean he has no legal basis to stand
on
uh not even remotely these cases are
getting kind of
laughed out of the courts um they had
been all day
uh i don't even know if this is intended
uh really to be
a serious legal move or if these
lawsuits are instead
just intended to delegitimize the
election in the eyes of his supporters
um there have already been reports that
trump is considering running again in
2024 and
these lawsuits might be more uh an
appeal to the gop base they certainly
aren't an appeal to the supreme court
we know that the u.s president has said
that he would like to see
this go to the supreme court but if we
talk about the
situation in the year 2000 we were
talking about one state the state of
florida
what what the president is talking about
now involves many states
does that make it more or less likely to
go to the supreme court
far less likely so really the only
scenario in which the supreme court
could hand donald trump the election
would be if the election came down to
one state and if that state was very
close
and most likely in this case it would be
in a state that was very close that was
allowing votes to come in
after election day in in essentially
where there had been accommodations for
covet 19.
uh donald trump's problem as you can
gather from
his response has been that he needs
votes to continue being counted in some
states to stop being counted in other
states
and he's simply behind in too many
states and in potentially
what will be the deciding state of
pennsylvania
he's losing uh pretty badly or look he's
not losing yet but looks poised to lose
badly
um just counting votes that were
received on election day
so if the votes are that he needs to
make up or spread out across
states there's no kind of single vehicle
for the supreme court to intervene as
there was
in bush professor ziggler i've got about
30 seconds let me ask you for our
international viewers donald trump he
could
you as you mentioned legally run again
for president in the year
2024 right he could yeah
and and that seems to be something he's
already
mulling over okay but we will see what
happens there
is an eternity in politics between now
and 2024
professor mary ziegler as always
professor we appreciate your insights
tonight thank you
thanks for having me you're watching dw
news live from berlin here is a reminder
of our top story final vote still being
counted in the race for the white house
joe biden appears to be closing in on
victory with just a handful of states
still to declare
president trump has mounted a series of
legal challenges
against the vote counting process
i'll be back at the top of the hour with
more world news followed by the day i
hope to see you then
you